un nouveau confinement pour 16
départements dont les yvelines depuis
samedi 19 mars les commerces non
essentiels ont baissé le rideau pour les
magasins présents en dehors des centres
commerciaux des aménagements ou était
prévu on va rester ouvert en click and
collect vient d'avoir les informations
donc bon c'est un peu embêtant est ce
qu'on sera pas ouvert avec les clients
mais bon
on pourra toujours à subir les phares
les réservations et surtout redonner les
commandes et clairoix pour cette
commerçante qui a notamment perdu un
proche du coc vide ce confinement est
justifié employé dans une mercerie la
boutique reste ouverte non sans
précaution on va limiter le nombre de
personnes qui vont rentrer dans le
magasin de façon à ce que il ya au moins
deux ou trois personnes
si on est trois à servir une personne
pour chacun les autres personnes
attendront dehors une personne qui rend
qui sortira une personne qui rentrera
mais c'est une personne je veux dire ça
sera pas une personne et les enfants
c'est la personne toute seule du côté
des clients les avis sont partagés entre
lassitude et compréhension je fais de la
lecture je fais de la peinture je vais
j'ai des copines je fais de la
méditation je fais attention choses
comme ça je m'ennuie pas et finissent
par nous gaver sérieusement on peut plus
rien faire nous empêche de vivre
sérieusement que ce soit les petits
commerçants comme les ouvriers faut dire
ce qui est beaucoup de pertes d'emploi à
cause de tout ça - et en aide ménagère
si j'ai pas de travail je fais comment
si certains magasins ont dû fermer des
commerces dits essentiels ont été
ajoutés à la liste comme les fleuristes
ou les librairies